not all of us are ever going to be the
champion but we can't go the distance we
can put up a great fight
nothing's braver than knowing you're
going to lose you're going to take a
beating you're done but if you stood up
to this class bully you did something
that no one else had to custody them
you want to leave some Footprints you
know on the canvas of life and
they don't have to be big ones everyone
doesn't have to be a world champion it's
just the fact that you gave it your best
could I that's a rocky philosophy you
never expected to be a champion he just
wanted to go the distance and have a
little dignity and that's pretty much
the ongoing theme
they come into you
to millions of years
of instinctual development
culturally spiritually in actual genetic
development they know how to push the
maternal but
again how tough you are
we all need it
to be a great man you need to be
nurtured in the proper way reinforced
pushed the validated loved and also
reprimanded when you're not doing what
you should do God is a very very strong
element a cohesive element
but there's always a but you ever tried
praying to yourself
put yourself in advance not in the
mirror but go okay this is what I want
you can call it positive reinforcement
and there's so many different
terminologies for that but actually look
at you request something if we are in
fear of something I pray to you not to
be afraid I pray for you to be
successful I pray for you to have
proper knowledge and Sympathy for the
planet in general to you not something
other which is great
but narrowing it down to
you praying to you
I think it's an interesting concept
keep punching I've I've known a lot of
people
that are in real life I'm not so nice
but the perception is incredible
they're very smart
they didn't go Toe to Toe they went
around they navigated
they went left when you expect to go
right they went low when they expect to
go high and vice versa instead of
throwing a roundhouse hook
they walked away they go home
well I thought he was going to unload on
me no and right away you put people at
ease and then you get your point across
like Apollo Creed says be a thinker not
a stinker use your brains to get ahead
and not your muscles
be thankful clever ingenious even the
guys that were are billionaires they
started out as underdogs no one gave it
to them someone in the family perhaps
had to earn it and pass it on but that
first one the guy that went into the
unknown
unprepared but prepared mentally but
perhaps I'm prepared for what was going
to
come at him
from so many different directions and
when I say that come at him I mean
those obstacles that wanted to defeat
him including his own fear and they were
overcome so as Rocky would say it ain't
over
until it's over I had a very tumultuous
upbringing very physical and
rough father rough everything and I was
thin I just was not genetically would
you say a mesomorph I plus I was an
ectober yeah
and I went to see a film one day and it
altered my life completely it was uh
Steve Reeves and Hercules Unchained and
when he struck that pose
that's who I want to be that's that's a
man that's oh my God and I ran out of
the theater after that
and with the junkyard and started
lifting little brake drums or anything
that I could lift it was like 30 pounds
whatever and I never stopped
and I did build on Armor it was like I
felt I could really take care of myself
I could
inflict punishment rather than take
punishment and I never stopped
it but I always felt that a lot of guys
it's a lot of action guys have no heart
and you can see in their films all they
did was kick ass they never get hurt
ever
not a bloody nose
that's not real
the audience can't relate to that
everybody gets hurt
every it either metaphorically
symbolically or physically they get hurt
and you root for that person who gets
hurt get up
because we all get knocked down and
that's just a CREDO that followed my
whole life that he's not a Pillar of
Strength he's a pillar of dominoes it's
just
I mean seriously
done but it depends how well you know
yourself I knew my personality that if I
sold it
that was probably a million plus by
today's dollars
a millionaire and someone else did it
and it was successful I would have never
forgiven myself I would have been a
broken
embittered man for the rest of my life
so I realized we have in our in our
entire Futures about three or four
serious Crossroads
and that was my first one that's what a
real serious Crossroad where this is
life-altering
and it's not about money I know I will
be destroyed and I will destroy everyone
around me I'll be such a miserable human
being for selling out this is what the
whole movie was about it's not selling
out I just know how I work I know my
engine will do and I would I would have
been I don't want to get too overly
dramatic but I would have been
dead
I wouldn't I wouldn't have survived I
mean I would have just been so miserable
that my life would just spiral I know it
because I sold out
and I said no because when you're broke
I actually mastered the art of poverty
for a while you know you figured out all
right we have spaghetti one day a week
and this and that I managed and I still
had this blatant optimism but if I had
sold out oh my God and I knew it
and they tried I mean believe me they
try this is it this is my only chance
because I was always getting casts as I
thought that was it I was only beating
up Woody Allen being so when I wrote
this I wrote it as a thug he's a thug
but he can't even do that well he can't
break the guy's thumbs he can't do
anything he's really a gentle guy I
don't like to argue I don't like stress
I don't like conflict but sometimes you
have to face the conflict and the stress
and the source of that and get it out of
the way
don't keep it inside
somehow you have to purge yourself of
this thing that's eating you alive but
sometimes you just have to
offend someone who's offending you
that's fair and it takes courage
actually it takes courage to do a lot of
things
it takes a lot of guts
to stay in school it's courage it takes
courage to get up every morning in
bravery and pushing yourself when you
don't want to to go to work just to
apply food for yourself and your family
it takes courage to stick your head
above the crowd and voice your own
opinion even though it's not a popular
one but it's one that you feel
so deep in your soul that you have to
get it out you can't go through life
living on life
quite often you just have to stand up
and grab Life by the throat and not let
go until you succeed
courage
you all have it
it's just pushing the red button the
world ain't all sunshine and rainbows
it's a very mean and nasty place and I
don't care how tough you are it will
beat you to your knees and keep you
there permanently if you let it you me
or nobody is going to hit as hard as
life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take and
keep moving forward
that's how winning is done
now if you know what you're worth to go
out and get what you're worth but you
got to be willing to take the hits and
not pointing fingers saying you ain't
where you want to be because of him or
her or anybody
cowards do that and that ain't you
you're better than that
I I thought let me try a formula imagine
if you this is what you do you woke up
you're now a gangster you're in this
world but you decide you're you're the
same personality you're not gonna all of
a sudden be the gangster guy with the
dead eyes yeah you know everyone's
posing and being tough and that kind of
thing now you're charming you're
outgoing you're exactly the same you are
until
somebody crosses that line and
disrespect me and then you're back to
yourself again so I thought why don't I
just be me you know I mean try to be
that so and which is the hardest thing
to do in acting is to actually be
yourself right it sounds easy but soon
as you're in front of a camera you lock
up I don't care who it is you're still
to this day yeah there's always that
butterfly thing
and it takes years of learning how to as
you know to calm down in front of the
camera where you can sit there and
scratch yourself that'll always feel
like what do I do with my hands that
kind of thing well that's what has
happened in this show that I I'm
basically playing
me as the fella who's a gangster but
he's he's also charming and nice he's
not trying to be threatening yeah yeah
but if he's threatened by other bad guys
then you see him kicking the gear